[Music]
so i've covered some quick tips on the
first three food utilities and housing
and i wanted to just quickly talk about
transportation give you guys some hope
some encouragement some tips to save in
those areas
as inflation keeps getting crazier and
crazier so let's talk about this
as you know the average price of a
gallon of gas has skyrocketed here in
tennessee it's well over four bucks
probably higher where you are and so
let's talk about gas real quick gas
rewards and cash back programs can be
some good options for you right now
we've got a gross grocery store called
kroger here and they've got some rewards
programs if you're already buying your
groceries or you're not even buying
anything i get three cents off every
gallon not going to change your life but
hey every little bit helps and there's
some great cash back apps out there like
get upside and gas buddy that can show
you deals around your area and give you
cash back for the gas that you're
already getting
and speaking of gas buddy that's one of
my favorite apps to track the cheapest
gas prices the cheapest gas is not
always at my local wholesale club like
costco or sam's club sometimes it's at
the the local shell down the street and
so you can use gas buddy or waze to find
the cheapest gas prices in your area
some great apps to have there on your
phone some other ways that you may not
have thought about uh make less trips
that's right make one trip instead of
seven if you've got some errands to run
just plan better people that's all i'm
asking you to do
and carpool america's favorite pastime
carpooling that's right great way to
have some human connection while saving
some money whether it's to the office
to school with the kids kids soccer game
whatever you got going on figure out a
way to have less cars on the road less
gas being purchased
now when it comes to transportation we
got to talk about car prices the car
market is still pretty wild out there
i'm hoping for good things to be
happening sometime soon but let's talk
about some ways to save on cars number
one the best way to save just don't buy
a car right now
i don't know why but it's like when the
car market goes crazy we all want to go
out and get a car
so let's just slow down and go do we
actually need a car if the answer is no
i wouldn't be buying a car right now
that's it so if your car is working it
gets from a to b let's just take a chill
pill
number two shop around for auto
insurance rates this one is huge
you just have had your auto insurance
for years and years and years you
haven't shopped around
and that can free up you know 30 40 50
bucks in your budget every month when
you realize you're not getting that
great of a deal
so check out our friends at xander
insurance you can go to
ramseysolutions.com we can help you shop
around all of the best auto insurance
companies to get you the best deal on
those premiums
and carpool co-workers we mentioned this
but this is another way that you can get
around some of the craziness
is uh carpooling you know here ramsay
solutions we have over a thousand team
members james lives nearby kelly you
know maybe a carpool to save some money
on gas for a little while and of course
sharing a car if you've got a second car
maybe you and your spouse share one for
a little while that can be a huge help
and lastly if you do have to get a car
budget for it pay cash don't get ripped
off at this dealership
and i know out there they're gonna say
hey finance you'll save a thousand
dollars by financing with us you say no
thank you sir and you check that
contract out for the sale and you look
and see all of the different fees they
tacked on there and you say nope nope
not paying that not paying that i'm
walking away that's what you do i don't
want you to pay anything more than sales
tax and
maybe a small small doc fee
anything outside of that their premium
care their warranties avoid that like
the plague they are ripping you off so
find a reputable dealership maybe go
private sale and negotiate on facebook
marketplace or craigslist do what you
got to do but do not get ripped off
during these crazy times so there you go
that wraps our series on how to combat
inflation protect your four walls hope
that was helpful a lot of empathy for
you all out there dealing with this
trying to find the margin in your budget
which is what it comes down to how do we
spend less how do we make more how do we
have that margin so that we don't feel
the pinch of inflation